[Music]
foreign
you're watching the Press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive and it's time to see
what's making the headlines with Daily
Mirror columnist Susie Boniface and
Deputy editor of conservative home Henry
Hill they'll be with us from now until
just before midnight reviewing the
papers as they come in so let's have a
look at what's on some of those front
pages the times leads with that planned
nurses strike announced today there are
fears of chaos if doctors and nurses
strike in the coming weeks according to
the Daily Mail
The Daily Telegraph is also leading with
nurse strikes branding them as the most
extreme yet
must launch AI startup to rival chat GPT
that's on the front page of the ft
police are set to Crackdown on terror
groups ahead of the king's coronation
that's according to the Daily Mirror
The Daily Express leads with King's
Pride of both his sons William and Harry
ahead of the coronation
The Daily Star headlining with French
forecasters sneaking ahead of the
British forecasters in naming the latest
storm storm Noah
and reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on your screen during
the program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you're
watching us
let's bring in Susie Boniface and Henry
Hill who are here to review the papers
with us this evening great to see you
both thanks so much for joining us uh
Susie let's kick off with you if that's
okay a lot of the front page is leading
on nurses strikes of course after the
RCN knocking back that payoffer earlier
yep so what's happened is uh there's
been a payoff of about five percent and
um two unions have voted on that and the
announcement came out today one of them
uh the Royal College of nurses uh has
about 61 or so I think it was who most
of whom 54 of those people had actually
did vote uh to reject the payoff of 61
turnout and another one Unison had a
smaller turnout at 50 something percent
and um they had a greater action vote
but they had a small turnout to um
accept the offer now this is kind of a
bit academic because there's two more
unions yet to have their results they're
coming back on April the 28th that's GMB
and unite they're slightly smaller but
they've they've also got a say in it and
what's going to happen is actually in
the next couple of weeks is there's
something called a meeting of the NHS
staff Council and they are going that's
where you have lots of unions and
employer Representatives all on there
and they vote whether or not to accept
the pay offers in plural that I've that
have been made by the government and all
those unions and employers on that
Council have a vote that is weighted
according to how many you know how big
the union is how many people they
represent and RCN and Unison have some
of the the biggest and most important
votes on that Council so there's a
process to go through yet everything you
can see in the papers tomorrow is just
like the first part of this it is not
definite what's happening next at any
stage the RCN which had recommended its
members except this payoffer has been
told by a majority of its members that
they don't want to accept it so now the
RCN is having to go back and negotiate
again
um the government from their point of
view they're hoping that the unions are
split and therefore that the strikes
will somehow fragment but what may well
happen is the Royal College of Nursing
will have to go back to its members
ballot again on strike action and may
well see that the union with the most
most nurses is going to be out on strike
again perhaps into the winter maybe even
into next year this does need sorting
out and it's it's just very very messy
at the moment it's probably the best way
to define it yeah Messi is a good word
certainly uh these two big Health unions
very divided now on on how they view
this payoffer but one thing's clear
Henry is that this is certainly going to
mean more disruption for patients the
next round of strikes is going to impact
emergency care and Cancer Care for the
first time
yeah absolutely this is going to be one
of the things that is really concerning
both the government and you know people
who are using the NHS is that the gloves
are coming off there will be an
expansion as you say of the areas of the
NHS which this strike will cover
including accident and emergency
departments there are also concerns in
some quarters that if they if the RCN do
proceed with this new strike action and
as Susie says the process is not
concluded yet they may end up
coordinating with the junior doctors and
that could be even more disruptive so
there is a real incentive for for all
parties I think to try and get around
the table and sort this out because
whilst Health unions are saying that
this is not going to be leading to
excess deaths and I don't think anyone
yeah they will for some extent it must
necessarily do that if you're targeting
accident and emergency care that's not
stuff that you can delay that's not
stuff that you can push back and
reschedule accidents and Emergency Care
has to be provided there and then that's
what that department is for so if you're
understaffing it or if it ends up under
staff that is going to have a direct
consequence for patients and that is
clearly something that the government
should be extremely worried about
because I think that the problem the
government has with all of this is that
ultimately the odds of whatever public
opinion is on the but on the on the
value of the strikes the public will not
accept a government presiding over at
NHS which is actually Turning Away
patients at the door of hospitals it
will be a sort of winter of discontent
for the conservative government so I'm
sure this is extremely worrying for
Richie sunak and the health secretary
uh yeah I'm sure it is certainly very
concerning for a lot of patients uh
Susie the the front page of the Daily
Mail also raises another good point that
we could see nurses and Junior doctors
striking at the same time because of
course Junior doctors are walking out as
well at the moment
yeah you could also see kangaroos
hopping down the High Street it's not
very likely though and the Royal College
of Nursing has said they don't want to
coordinate the strikes in that way so
that's a slightly panicky front page in
fact all the front pages are making um
talking about the chaos and the
disruption of the strikes and isn't it
awful uh and I think we need to bear in
mind that the reason these strikes are
happening is because the NHS is already
in chaos it's already disrupted there
are 133 000 vacancies in the NHS because
the pay is so bad because the job
retention is so bad because the working
in it itself is is although it should be
a prestigious and honorable career it's
it's not one that people do and get much
pleasure out of sometimes it would seem
and that means that's 135 3 000
vacancies that's almost 10 of the NHS
total Workforce right we're 10 down
already and how does anybody how does
the editor of the daily mail or the
times off how does anyone think that
that NHS is not already in chaos if
you've only got 90 of the staff that you
need and of course some of them are
going to be off six some of them are
going to be on holidays some of them are
going to be having a rest day on their
road today you just do not have enough
people and enough money in that system
to operate that system and there hasn't
been for probably a decade and that's
the chaos and the disruption that we've
already got and so I think it's a it's a
bit Rich really I mean a lot of the
newspapers have to be perfectly Fair
um been reporting for for years about
the growing problems in the NHS I don't
think all of them have necessarily
attributed them correctly
um but the fact that we have the chaos
and the disruption of strikes of a day
here in the couple of days there maybe
four days in the other direction kind of
thing when the people on picket lines I
think it is is quite incredible that
this is being seen as the thing that's
causing the nhs's problems we all
remember we we all remember what
happened a couple of years ago we all
know what happens happening before the
pandemic we all know what happened
during austerity we know where these
problems have come from so the the tone
of the government and the NHS employers
and some of the media about how this is
somehow the fault of the strikes that we
have the backlogs and the problems and
the and the the issues in the NHS Is Not
Gonna Fly I think with the public and as
Henry has pointed out I mean at the
moment there's more than 50 of the
public in polls are fully supportive of
these strikes and so the government
doesn't have much case here you're
they're going to have to come back with
a bigger offer because the alternative
is political suicide yeah you raise a
very good point in terms of how the
front pages are covering it very much
focusing on the disruption Susie Henry
thanks very much we're back with you in
just a moment uh coming up President
Biden in tears in County Mayo will tell
you why after this short break
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview and with me now is Deputy editor
of conservative home Henry Hill and
Daily Mirror columnist Susie Boniface uh
good to see you both again Henry uh to
you first if I may uh really um moving
story that we saw unfold in in Ireland
today on the on the front page of the
Daily Telegraph uh Joe Biden uh reduced
to Tears by a priest uh who who'd met
his son before he died tell us more
about that
oh well you you summed it up quite
nicely basically uh Joe Biden was
visiting a Catholic shrine in the
Republic of Ireland and apparently this
was completely unplanned and he didn't
know about it the one of the priests who
worked at The Shrine was actually the
one who delivered the last rights to his
late to the president's late son before
he passed away uh so an incredibly
moving moment for Joe Biden uh here and
produced to tears I think quite
understandably in a very humanizing
moment which helps to you know often I
think we often do bcbc politicians only
as either sort of hate figures or in
their Pomp and it's always nice to be
not you know obviously the circumstances
are quite horrible but it's always nice
to be reminded of the The Human Side of
these people that we that we shout at
and same mean things about so that's the
story
yeah well well summed up Henry I'm sorry
if I stole your punchline there um Susie
uh your take on Joe Biden's visit uh to
Ireland I mean obviously he's got you
know very strong family connections but
there seems to be a lot of electoral
logic as well in terms of a lot of U.S
presidents choosing to go to Ireland
before an election year
yeah there's some there's some vote
one in it I'm sure for Biden
um it I mean he's about as Irish as I am
which is not very you know it's it's a
couple of hundred years ago in the 19th
century quite a lot of people were Irish
and it seems that when you go to America
you sort of become more Irish the
further away you get from it whereas the
rest of us you know we just we are of
where we are born I mean Joe Biden's an
American he's not Irish no matter how
much it might suit him or how much he
might have Nostalgia for the old country
he's American not Irish
um and don't begrudge the man his trip
or his moment with the priest I don't
begrudge
um County Mayo and other places the
chance to sort of claim the leader of
the Free World as one of their own well
done it seems a bit much though if I was
a taxpayer that was putting the bill for
some of this that he's basically having
an old American man's trip a family
holiday uh in effect and calling it a
state visit
um it's a holiday it's the kind of thing
lots of men in their 80s might go and do
if they've got some Irish background I
think it's sweet but useless
Susie I love your cynicism there a quick
thought from you Henry on the front page
of the Ft Elon Musk to launch an AI
startup to rival chatpt
I mean for me this is sort of finally
Elon Musk going back to you know what I
think Elon Musk is for if you're going
to have a crazy Tech billionaire you
don't want him wasting time buying
Twitter right Elon Musk whatever
whatever you think of his politics or
his personality he was investing in
going to Mars he was investing in
electric cars he was investing in sort
of all this kind of stuff and now he
said he's going to launch a challenger
company to the main Ai and that's
actually a really important story
because AI is going to be transformative
the technology is coming along in Leaps
and Bounds and we've already seen The
Perils of having this technology in the
hands of one American company there was
a graphic uh one of the graphic AIS we
found globally you can't use it to mock
the Chinese government because the CEO
of that company wants to make money in
China so having competition on these
important Technologies is really
important and I hope that Elon Musk
makes a better job of it than he has of
Twitter